今回のセクションでは実際に今まで学んできたことを使って
デモのVue.jsのアプリケーションを一つ作っていきたいと思います
具体的にはこういう今日何を食べるかを悩んだ時に2択にして
お寿司かハンバーガーだったらハンバーガーかなと
ハンバーガーと焼肉だったらこれもハンバーガーかなと
でも麺形と比べたら麺形かなみたいな感じに
簡単に2択で選んで今食べたいものを決めるようなアプリを作りたいと思います
このセクションでは新しい知識は一切説明しません
なので知識だけを得たいという方はスキップしていただいても問題ありません
逆にVue.jsの機能は分かったけれども
それを使ってどうこんな風にアプリケーションを作っていけばいいのか分からないという方は
このデモのアプリを通してざっくりこんな風にするんだなみたいに
考え方のきっかけにしていただければなと思います
では早速VS Codeに移動して
まずはCreateViewで新しいプロジェクトを作りますね
npmCreateViewAtLatestとします
プロジェクトの名前は何でもいいんですけれども
デモAppとかとしておきますね
タイプスクリプトは入れないでJSXもなし
ビュールーターやPeniumもなしでテスト系もなし
ESLintとPrettyだけ入れたいと思います
このデモAppのフォルダが作られますので
これをVS Code上でファイルとかのオープンフォルダとかから選んで開きますね
開くとこんな風にフォルダがたくさん作られているのが分かると思います
一度不要なものは全て削除しますね
ちょっとグローバルのCSSに関しては使わないので
アセットフォルダごと消したいと思います
コンポーネンツも中のものは全て削除して
min.jsのmin.cssのインポートも消しておきたいと思います
ESLintに関してはここのエッセンシャルの部分を
recommendedに変更しておきたいと思います
でApp.viewも一度ですね
スクリプトの中やテンプレートの中やスタイルタグの中を消して
綺麗にしておきたいと思います
この状態で始めますね
まずテンプレートの中でメインタグを置いて
タイトルということでH1タグで
今日何食べるみたいなものを書いておきますね
これをブラウザ上で表示したいので
ターミナルでまずnpm installで
全てのパッケージをインストールします
でnpm run devですね
これで開発用のサーバーが立ちます
でこんな風にちょっと分かりやすいように
右側にブラウザを置いて
そこからアクセスしました
そうするとこんな風に
今日何食べるというH1タグが出ているのが分かると思います
でちょっとこのメインタグの中身を
全て真ん中に持ってきたいので
ちょっとこのスタイルを書きますね
まずメインタグを真ん中に配置したいので
まず横幅を適当に
350ピクセルみたいに決めます
その上でそのメインタグを真ん中に持ってきたいので
マージンで上下には適当に100ピクセルとして
で左右をオートにします
こうするとですねこんな風に真ん中に来てくれます
ただH1タグの中の文字が左寄りになっていますので
これもセンターにしたいと思います
のでテキストアラインとしてセンターと
こうするとこんな風に
今日何食べるという文字がセンターに来るのが分かると思います
では早速ですねこの下に2つの食べ物を置きたいと思います
でこの時この2つの食べ物の形は同じですよね
なので1つのコンポーネントを使って
それを使い回して2つ置くみたいにしたいと思います
これですね次のレクチャーで紹介します